so wie das dauert noch ein bisschen hier
wird noch über die tagesordnung
abgestimmt da gab es im vorfeld ein
unglaubliches hin und her so wie man es
selten hat morgen soll es eine
abstimmung über die worüber wir eben
schon geredet haben die impfpflicht
geben ich frage jetzt nochmal meine
kollegin ines trams
was genau war da los welche anträge gibt
es jetzt überhaupt morgen über die
abgestimmt werden soll wer ist
eigentlich verantwortlich für dieses
unglaubliche hin und her und auch eine
konkrete tagesordnung gibt es ja
anscheinend immer noch nicht
das ist die große frage wer trägt für
dieses wirrwarr du hast es sogenannt die
verantwortung richtig und schwer
verständlich ist dass aus dem antrag auf
eine impfpflicht also das prestige
projekt von kanzler scholz und seinem
gesundheitsminister lauterbach auf eine
allgemeine impfpflicht ab 18 jahren und
dem antrag auf eine impfpflicht ab 50
nun ein kompromiss antrag auf eine
impfpflicht ab 60 jahren über nacht wenn
man so will geworden ist man versucht
man hat gemerkt man bekommt keine eigene
mehrheit zustande in der ampelkoalition
die fdp war da doch sehr stand da sehr
auf der bremse nun hofft man mit diesem
entgegenkommen auf ein höheres alter
nämlich 60 jahre doch noch die union als
größte oppositionspartei
zu gewinnen zu können aber das ist alles
andere als sicher aus dem
gesundheitsausschuss heute morgen gab es
positive stimmen ja man sei bereit zu
gesprächen aber genau so hat man auch
den fraktionschef der unionsfraktion im
bundestag märz gehört der ganz klar
gesagt hat also wir sind nicht
diejenigen die der ampel koalition
zu einer mehrheit verhelfen wollen und
verhelfen müssen dazu kam ein großes
gerangel um die tagesordnung das noch
nicht beendet ist mit blick auf morgen
in welcher reihenfolge dann abgestimmt
wird denn die reihenfolge der abstimmung
die kann tatsächlich auch einen einfluss
haben welcher dieser anträge dann eine
mehrheit bekommt also insgesamt denke
ich bei einem großen wichtigen thema wo
es so wichtig ist die menschen im land
die gesellschaft mit zu nehmen
zeigt sich da die regierung aber genauso
auch die opposition ja von keiner guten
seite und ich denke die leute draußen
sind nur verwirrt
das mit sicherheit das auch beim thema
isolation quarantäne auch da ist man
sicherlich verwirrt vielleicht wissen
wir nachher mehr wir hören jetzt noch
mal rein ich glaube es wird immer noch
über die geschäftsordnung für morgen
debattiert aber wir hören einfach mal
rein möchte das sind also
selbstverständlichkeiten wie sie die
menschen zurückgegeben haben aber
immerhin den ländern haben sie ein
instrument an die hand gegeben notstand
oder katastrophengebiete in deutschland
auszurufen und nach wie vor unter ein
ganz schlimmes corona regime zu stellen
von diesen notstandsgebieten in
deutschland gibt es noch drei stück alle
von der spd nominiert notstandsgebiet in
mecklenburg vorpommern notstands
katastrophengebiet in hamburg und
offenbar notstands und
katastrophengebiet dieser deutsche
bundestag und deshalb werde ich mich
hier zu wort
deshalb werde ich mich hier zu wort und
problematisieren die nach wie vor hier
bestehende testpflicht und masten
pflicht die außerhalb des deutschen
bundestages schon drei meter wir merken
es geht immer noch um die
geschäftsordnungsdebatte also es ist
jetzt im augenblick schwer abzuschätzen
wann es wirklich losgeht mit der
regierungsbefragung deswegen frage ich
nochmal weiter bei ines trams es gab ja
heute morgen ganz viele meldungen dass
jetzt gesundheitsminister lauterbach
eine kehrtwende hingelegt hat erst hieß
es man müsse in nicht mehr in isolation
und quarantäne ab ersten mal jetzt doch
wieder was ist denn da eigentlich los
man hat im augenblick den 1
selbst die regierung weiß nicht ganz so
genau wie sie eigentlich weitermachen
soll bei diesem thema
naja ich denke das grundlegende problem
ist dass wir ja schon jetzt seit einigen
wochen erleben wir erleben wenn man so
will einen gespaltenen
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach wir
haben ihn bevor er minister wurde ja
immer als mahner und warner
als vorreiter des so genannten teams
vorsicht in der korona bekämpfung erlebt
und nun als teil der ampelkoalition als
minister gesundheitsminister in der
ampelkoalition muss er auf die anderen
parteien namentlich eben auch die fdp
rücksicht nehmen und ja gestern hieß es
noch es soll keine isolation mehr
vorgeschrieben empfohlen notwendig seien
bei einer corona
infizierung dann am späten späten abend
in der talkshow lanz bei uns im zdf hat
der gesundheitsminister das wieder
revidiert kassiert auch da erneut denke
ich ist das problem die menschen draußen
sind seit wochen schon verwirrt mit
blick auf regeln die regional
unterschiedlich angewandt werden mit
blick auf die korona bekämpfung und nun
eben dieser spezielle punkt isolierung
oder nicht isolierung nach einer einer
infektion ich denke ja das wird auch
heute in der regierungsbefragung
thema sein und
wir werden sehen wie sich der kanzler
der ja denke ich mal auch für seinen
gesundheitsminister spricht
da rechtfertigt oder zumindest dieses
heck meck und dieses kassieren über
nacht erklären wird bis hierhin erstmal
herzlichen dank ich höre dass der redner
von der afg fertig ist jetzt hören wir
noch mal rein vielleicht hat man sich
jetzt geeinigt oder schon abgestimmt auf
die
tagesordnung für morgen und die
regierungsbefragung fängt hoffentlich
gleich an eigentlich sollte ist diese
ganze debatte und abstimmung über
tagesordnung erst morgen geben wir sind
selber wie sie merken etwas überrascht
aber wir hören jetzt erstmal rein
vielleicht geht es jetzt gleich los und
das werden wir auch morgen am donnerstag
tun und ich lade sie herzlich ein morgen
in der ältestenratssitzung wo das thema
hingehört über die weiteren maßnahmen
zur pandemie im deutschen bundestag und
in ausschüssen mit mir zu diskutieren
bitte
damit kommen wir jetzt
zur tagesordnung
die befragung der bundesregierung
die bundesregierung hat mitgeteilt dass
heute der bundeskanzler herr olaf scholz
zur verfügung steht
der bundeskanzler sie haben das wort für
ihre einleitenden ausführungen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die
entsetzlichen bilder ausputzer haben uns
alle tief erschüttert
russische soldaten haben dort vor ihrem
rückzug ein massaker an ukrainischen
zivilisten verübt darunter kinder frauen
und alte menschen die
von russland verbreitete zynische
behauptung es handle sich bei diesem
thema um eine inszenierung fällt auf
diejenigen zurück die diese lügen
verbreiten die ermordung von zivilisten
ist ein kriegsverbrechen
um es klar zu sagen die täter und ihre
auftraggeber müssen zur rechenschaft
gezogen werden darum unterstützen wir
alle internationalen bemühung solche
greueltaten nun minutiös zu
dokumentieren und schonungslos
aufzuklären in butter und auch darüber
hinaus
das sollten wir ja nicht vergessen wir
müssen ja damit rechnen dass wir noch
weitere solche bilder sehen werden auch
die europäische union hat der ukraine
alle hilfe in dieser angelegenheit
zugesagt
meine damen und herren unterdessen geht
das töten des russischen militärs weiter
unvermindert
und deshalb fordere ich an dieser stelle
noch einmal den russischen präsidenten
auf
beenden sie diesen zerstörerischen und
selbstzerstörerischen krieg sofort
ziehen sie ihre truppen aus der ukraine
ab
und bis das geschieht setzen wir
weiterhin alles daran die ukraine
bestmöglich zu unterstützen
immer abgestimmt mit unseren freunden
und verbündeten
dazu gehört auch
dass wir aus den aktuellen beständen der
bundeswehr waffen liefern können
alles das was sinnvoll ist und schnell
wirkt das wird geliefert
ich weiß das
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht alles unternimmt was
angesichts der beschlusslage unserer
alliierten und mit blick auf die
fähigkeiten der bundeswehr machbar ist
diese regierung hat
anders als ihre vorgängerin beschlossen
waffen zu liefern und seither tun wir
das
die klare prämisse bleibt
dabei aber auch klar mit allen
entscheidungen die wir treffen
werden wir sicherstellen dass die
nato-partner keine kriegspartei werden
wir haben neben der militärischen
unterstützung über die ich gesprochen
habe und die wir täglich leisten und
auch weiter leisten werden auch
humanitäre unterstützung zur verfügung
gestellt für die ukraine und die
nachbarländer
noch mal neu fast eine halbe milliarde
euro zusätzlich zu den zwei milliarden
die wir den letzten jahren bereits zur
verfügung gestellt haben und diese
zivile hilfe werden wir fortsetzen
erst gestern hat die bundes
außenministerin hier in berlin zu einer
unterstützungs konferenz für moldau
gebieten weil da ist eines der
ärmsten länder europas
es hat pro kopf mehr geflüchtete
aufgenommen als alle anderen länder und
es braucht und verdient unsere
unterstützung
hunderttausende kriegsflüchtlinge aus
der ukraine sind in den letzten wochen
nach deutschland gekommen und es werden
mehr werden
sie sind hier willkommen das will ich an
dieser stelle noch einmal sagen
und wir werden gemeinsam mit den ländern
in deutschland morgen wichtige
entscheidungen treffen was all die
fragen betrifft die damit zusammenhängen
registrierung unterbringung und
natürlich auch die gemeinsame
finanzierung
gesamtstaatliche aufgaben auch dies als
eine bemerkung von mir ich wünsche mir
dass wir nicht eine ewig lange
diskussionen über die finanziellen
fragen zwischen den verschiedenen ebenen
unseres landes haben sondern dass wir
uns schnell und zügig einigen zwischen
dem bund den ländern dass wir die
interessen der kommunen und landkreise
hier
berücksichtigen dass wir eine gute
einigung und verständigung haben damit
wir uns der eigentlichen aufgabe
zuwenden können wir helfen wir den
flüchtlingen die hier schutz gesucht
haben
und für uns alle sollte ein ansporn sein
die solidarität die die bürgerinnen und
bürger dieses landes jeden tag zeigen
denn es gibt sehr viel solidarität sehr
viel unterstützung überall in
deutschland und ich bin sehr dankbar
dafür diese hilfe ist wichtig und sie
tut gut
und schließlich werden wir den druck auf
russland weiter erhöhen zum beispiel mit
den sanktionen die wir auf den weg
gebracht haben die sind lange
vorbereitet lange bevor der krieg
ausgebrochen worden woche ist haben wir
darüber gesprochen
wir haben sie
vereinbart mit der eu-kommission und wir
sind dabei die aktuellen sanktionen noch
einmal zu verschärfen das fünfte paket
ist in der finalen debatte und es wird
noch einmal präzise dazu beitragen dass
russland die folgen dieses krieges spürt
auch um zu erreichen dass es den krieg
beendet
es muss unser ziel bleiben dass russland
diesen krieg nicht gewinnt das ist das
was hinter den aktivitäten steht die wir
unternehmen wenn es nun um waffen die
führung geht wenn es um finanzielle und
humanitäre unterstützung geht wenn es um
die aufnahme der flüchtlinge geht oder
um die sanktions pakete die wir globale
und weltweit vereinbaren und natürlich
gehört dazu auch dass wir die
abhängigkeiten reduzierenden dem wir uns
heute befinden
und dazu gehört natürlich auch die
reduktion der abhängigkeit vom import
russischer energie
wir wissen alle diese abhängigkeiten
sind über jahrzehnte gewachsen und sie
lassen sich nicht von einem tag auf den
anderen beenden
deshalb ist es sehr sehr wichtig dass
wir uns in europa gemeinsam auf den weg
gemacht haben genau das zu schaffen und
gemeinsam einen kurs abgesteckt haben
mit dem wir das auch tatsächlich tun
jetzt während dieses krieges aber die
weichen sind gestellt und sie werden
auch nach dem krieg weiter einen den
kurs vorgeben wenn wir zu gehen haben
und gleichzeitig geht es nicht nur darum
neue import linien möglich zu machen und
neue importkapazitäten und neue
vertragspartner zu finden sondern
langfristig auch die unabhängigkeit von
fossilen ressourcen zu organisieren die
dann tatsächlich eine sichere
perspektive für europa schafft und
gleichzeitig hilft den menschengemachten
klimawandel aufzuhalten
wir werden jetzt mit großer
geschwindigkeit lg kapazitäten an der
norddeutschen küste aufbauen wir werden
die netze ausbauen die dazu erforderlich
sind wir werden die im pop strukturen
für kohle öl und gas so organisieren
dass wir auf dauer nicht mehr abhängig
sind von den russischen importen das
werden wir mit nie gekannter
geschwindigkeit tun und heute hat das
kabinett dazu einen ganz wichtigen
beitrag geleistet mit einer entscheidung
die ohnehin zu den plänen diese
regierung zählte und diese sorgfältig
vorbereitet haben aber die jetzt
unbedingt und noch viel mehr notwendig
ist mit dem oster paket zum ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien in deutschland zur
stärkung der energienetze zeigen wir was
wir vorhaben jetzt erst recht werden wir
uns unabhängig machen von der nutzung
fossiler ressourcen das ist unsere
aufgabe
vielen dank bevor wir mit der befragen
beginn ein paar vorbemerkung von mir wir
haben jetzt über die fraktionen bereits
sehr viele wortmeldungen
gemeldet bekommen und in der kanzler
oder kanzlerin befragung ist es
üblicherweise so dass wir so verfahren
dass wir die fragesteller aufrufen dass
eine nachfrage gestellt werden kann ich
aber üblicherweise dann nicht mehr
weitere fragen über andere fraktionen
zum thema zu lassen sondern wir dann in
die nächst in den nächsten frage block
gehen nur dass das einmal noch mal
erklärt wird weil wir das bei anderen
befragung ja durchaus anders machen in
dem dann auch das fragerecht auf andere
fraktion übergeht zum gleichen thema
das einleitend noch mal damit dass für
alle fraktionen klar ist und ich rufe
zuerst zur befragung auf den kollegen dr
johann wadephul für die cdu csu fraktion
zum thema waffenlieferungen hat sich der
vorsitzende der grünen in deutschland
omid nouripour den vergangenen tagen
geäußert und er hat dazu gesagt dass die
leistung der
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht sehr unzureichend sei weil
keine hinreichende
synchronisation zwischen den wünschen
der ukraine und den möglichkeiten
deutschlands waffen zu liefern
stattfindet teilen sie diese auffassung
und wenn ja was gedenken sie zu tun um
die missstände abzustellen sie haben die
vorsitzenden der grünen völlig
missverstanden ich hatte gestern das
privileg mit ihm länger ein gespräch zu
führen und hat mir das gegenteil gesagt
da wie
der bade physiker nachfolger ich würde
dann die nachfrage darzustellen wie hat
er ihnen denn sein zusatz erklärt dass
er in dem gleichen interview darauf
hingewiesen hat dass größere mengen
schützenpanzer marder herr umständen die
in die ukraine verbracht werden könnten
und wo dies nicht geschehe und ich
verbinde das mit dem hinweis dass es
mehrere rüstungsunternehmen in
deutschland gibt die anfragen von der
ukraine haben dass waffen geliefert
werden könnten die ukraine
zahlungsbereit ist es aber an
genehmigungen seitens ihrer regierung
fehlt was sagen sie dazu ich möchte
gerne noch einmal darauf hinweisen dass
es ein bruch mit langen tradition ist
dass diese regierung anders als alle
ihren vorgängerinnen entschieden hat
überhaupt waffen in die ukraine und in
ein krisengebiet zu liefern das ist eine
richtige entscheidung die wir abgewogen
aber auch schnell getroffen haben es ist
interessant zu beobachten dass viele ddr
scheidungen der vergangenheit bisher
immer unterstützt hatten jetzt plötzlich
alle möglichen vorschläge haben wie es
jetzt weitergehen soll aber der
eigentliche weg die eigentliche
entscheidung war die dass wir es
überhaupt tun und jetzt nutzen wir
unsere möglichkeiten das machen wir
einerseits abgestimmt mit unseren
freundinnen und freunden in der nato und
der europäischen union weil es darum
geht dass alle in gleiche richtung gehen
und nicht unterschiedliche aktivitäten
unternehmen zwei treffen wir diese
entscheidung nach sorgfältiger
vorbereitung in den dazu notwendigen
gremien wo wir auch dafür sorgen dass
die sicherheit der bundesrepublik
deutschland dabei sorgfältig beachtet
wird und im übrigen ist es so dass wir
dabei alles was richtig und sinnvoll ist
auf den weg bringen
präsident der weide
ja das ist aber ich erwarte dann auch
eine antwort auf meine frage und ich
habe darauf hingewiesen dass
sie haben ja meine antwort auf ihre
frage bekommen allerdings müssen sie
sich noch mit dem thema beschäftigen
warum sie die politik der
bundesregierung die sie jetzt
unterstützen nicht richtig gefunden
haben früher zu anderen zeiten waren sie
früher war gerade wohl bitte ich weiß
aber sie haben eine nachfrage und sie
können ja nachher nochmal über die
nächsten fragesteller nachhaken die
nächste kollegin die die frage stellt
ist vieles polat von bündnis 90 die
grünen
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr bundeskanzler scholz ich
möchte romani rose zitieren romani rose
ist vorsitzender des zentralrats
deutscher sinti und roma und er warnte
erst kürzlich vor der ungleichbehandlung
von geflüchteten
romney und bezeichnete die bisher
bekannten einzelfälle von
diskriminierung als besorgniserregend er
drückt er drückte seine erwartung aus
dass jetzt zitiere ich dass unser staat
und klinischen roma die als
kriegsflüchtlinge nach deutschland
kommen den gleichen schutz gewährt
bekommen die alle anderen ukrainischen
staatsbürger innen aus wird sich unsere
bundesregierung genauso gegenüber den
ukrainischen roma kümmern wie es für die
anderen ukrainischen geflüchtete aus der
ukraine vorgesehen ist
schönen dank für ihre frage in der tat
geht es darum dass wir hier allen
gleichermaßen gerecht werden das haben
wir mit der entscheidung da die
europaweit getroffen worden es um die in
deutschland eben auch besondere
großzügigerweise auch ausgelegt worden
ist wir haben möglich gemacht dass
diejenigen hier einreisen können die
ukrainische staatsbürger sind und das
gilt für die von ihnen
genannten genauso wie für alle anderen
und darüber hinaus möglich gemacht dass
auch diejenigen die auf rechte zb in der
ukraine haben ebenfalls hier einreisen
können unabhängig von ihrer
staatsbürgerschaft und dieses basiere
ihrer frage nicht ging aber das finde
ich muss bei dieser gelegenheit gesagt
werden und deshalb kann ich ihnen
versichern die bundesregierung wird
alles dafür tun dass niemand
diskriminiert wird und dass alle gleich
behandelt wird obwohl
hat sie können eine nachfrage stellen
wenn sie möchten vielen dank frau
präsidentin
sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler scholz
vielen dank für diese für diesen für
diese hinweise ich werde dann noch mal
auf sie zukommen die zweite frage ist
unter den roh unter der roma minderheit
sind auch einige holocaust-überlebende
die bereits deutschland erreicht haben
wird es ähnlich wie bei den jüdischen
holocaust-überlebenden eine gemeinsame
evakuierungsaktion auch von
holocaust-überlebenden der
roma-minderheit
geben zusammen mit anderen
organisationen wie zum beispiel des
zentralrats
wir haben uns überhaupt verpflichtet
dass wir neben denjenigen die schutz
finden weil sie hierher kommen und
darüber haben sie gerade berichtet
darüber hinaus auch evakuieren vornehmen
die ganz ganz schwierig sind und sehr
sorgfältig vorbereitet werden es handelt
sich bei den holocaust-überlebenden um
hochbetagte
bürgern und bürger der ukraine die den
schrecklichen holocaust überlebt haben
und deshalb natürlich unseren besonderen
schutz verdienen und wir sind eng
abgestimmt mit den europäischen
verbündeten im hinblick auf das was
getan werden kann um das zu organisieren
das sind ja auch ganz komplizierte
transporte wie man sich angesichts des
alters und oft auch der
pflegebedürftigkeit sehr gut vorstellen
kann
die nächste frage stellt der kollege
leif erik holm von der armee fraktion
vielen dank frau präsidentin herr
bundeskanzler die bürger und unternehmen
dieses landes warten dringend auf
entlastung von den explodierten
energiepreisen das entlastungspaket hat
ihre regierung versprochen und es ist
wirklich dringend notwendig ein
musterhaushalt erwartet in diesem jahr
etwa 3200 euro an mehrausgaben für
energie für strom gas wasser kraftstoffe
und das alles muss dringend abgefedert
werden wir sehen doch die ergebnisse
bisher schon wir sehen pendler die nicht
mehr zur arbeit fahren manches schmeißen
ihren job hin weil es sich einfach nicht
mehr lohnt und das kann so doch nicht
weitergehen deswegen braucht es eine
entlassung zwar dringend in anderen
ländern um uns herum passiert das in
polen in belgien in frankreich italien
da sind die linderung schon längst in
kraft wo bleibt das entlastungspaket
ihrer regierung waren schafft es
deutschland unter einem kanzler scholz
nicht für schnelle entlastung der bürger
und unternehmen zu sorgen
schönen dank für die frage sie
ermöglicht mir noch einmal das lob das
sie darin untergebracht haben hier zu
verstärken tatsächlich ist es so dass
diese regierung zwei entlastungs paket
bereits auf den weg gebracht haben mit
einem umfang von zusammen etwa 30
milliarden euro ich glaube dass das in
der dimension an der spitze dessen liegt
was in europa überhaupt organisiert
worden ist und wir haben unsere
entsprechenden möglichkeiten genutzt wir
haben bei dieser gelegenheit all die
verschiedenen
schwierigen lagen der bürgern und bürger
berücksichtigt wir haben etwas getan für
diejenigen die auf grundsicherung
angewiesen sind wir haben für
geringverdiener etwas getan mit dem
höheren heizkostenzuschuss wir tun etwas
für ketten ein pendler mit einer
erhöhten entsprechenden
entfernungspauschale
wir machen etwas bad für die entlastung
bei den benzinkosten wir haben etwas
gemacht für diejenigen die auf den
öffentlichen nahverkehr angewiesen sind
wir haben steuerliche erleichterung auf
den weg gebracht was den arbeitnehmer
freibetrag den grundfreibetrag betrifft
wir haben etwas gibt auf den weg
gebracht für die familien eine
bonuszahlung und wir machen etwas als
sonderzahlung für die armen kinder in
dieser republik also da kommt eine ganze
menge zusammen danke dass sie es gelobt
haben der eine teil ist schon auf dem
gesetzgebungsverfahren
l hinter her und wenn sie mithelfen
kriegen wir auch die gesetzgebung mit
zweiter dritter lesung und zustimmung
des bundesrates mit eiltempo durch
bundestag und bundesrat
hier haben sie haben das recht seine
nachfragen mit verlaub herr
bundeskanzler aus ihren worten spricht
der blanke hohn für diejenigen die wenig
geld verdienen und 3300 euro
möglicherweise an mehrkosten in diesem
jahr haben und die davon eben noch nicht
in weiten teilen entlastet sind ich habe
die pendler angesprochen ich hab noch
nicht angesprochen die fuhrunternehmer
die jetzt schon vor lauter not auf die
straße gehen mit ihren großen lastern
dort straßenblockaden errichtet bei mir
in der heimat in mecklenburg vorpommern
beispielsweise und das sehen wir doch
dass es brennt an allen ecken und sie
sagen hier heute die entlastung kommt
bald auch beim sprit was ist denn bald
wann es ihres urabstimmung dann fertig
dann geht das gesetzgebungsverfahren los
wir wollen antworten die bürger wollen
antworten von ihnen wann kommt die
entlastung herr scholz also
dass sich die mühe machten könnten sie
die antwort aus ihren eigenen unterlagen
entnehmen dass eine gesetzgebung paket
ist bereits auf dem weg und ich will
ausdrücklich sagen
dass ich mir ja schon öfter gedanken
gemacht habe über ihr
demokratieverständnis aber gesetze
werden in diesem land nicht von der
regierung sondern vom deutschen
bundestag gemacht und das ist bekannt
da muss ich mal durchkommt
das
fragerecht geht jetzt an die kollegin
annika merten von der fdp fraktion
vielen dank frau präsidentin an die
kometen alles gut herr bundeskanzler der
ukrainische präsident seelands kiel hat
im zuge der verhandlungen mit russland
über ein friedensabkommen im
angriffskrieg russlands auf die ukraine
die neutralität der ukraine gegenzug für
sicherheitsgarantien der internationalen
gemeinschaft angeboten die
bundesregierung hat hierzu ihre
grundsätzliche bereitschaft signalisiert
sich an solchen sicherheitsgarantien für
die ukraine zu beteiligen
dies unterstützen wir ausdrücklich und
begleiten wir auch sehr gerne daher und
auch vor dem hintergrund dass bereits
auf dem eu-gipfel von versailles
erfolgten einstimmigen bekenntnis der eu
mitgliedstaaten zur unterstützung der
ukraine
auf ihrem weg in die eu die frage die
könnten solche sicherheitsgarantien
konkret aussehen kindern
in der tat ist es so dass gegenwärtig
verhandlung stattfinden der die frage
der neutralität eine rolle spielt was
das muss an dieser stelle gesagt werden
aus der sicht der ukraine ein großes
zugeständnis ist gegenüber dem aggressor
und bei allem was gegenwärtig in den
verhandlungen stattfindet ist mir ganz
wichtig zu sagen es darf nicht auf einen
diktat frieden hinauslaufen das muss
immer klar sein und wenn wir reden mit
der russischen seite wenn ich mit dem
russischen präsidenten rede dann mache
ich auch sehr klar es sind die ukraine
ukraine die über das was sie zu
vereinbaren bereits sind verhandeln
niemand sonst
[Applaus]
in diesem zusammenhang ist die frage der
sicherheitsgarantien angesprochen worden
die noch nicht ausbuchstabiert sind
selbstverständlich reden wir darüber
aber dass auch in der notwendigen
vertraulichkeit mit der ukraine und tun
das auch mit den anderen die
angesprochen sind ob sie dort eine rolle
spielen könnten es
entspringt eigentlich der natur der
sache dass sich das nicht weiter
konkretisieren lässt weil erst mal die
fragen die da garantiert werden müssen
geregelt werden müssen deshalb bitte ich
um nachsicht dass ich so allgemein
bleibe wie unsere erklärung bisher zu
diesem thema nur sein können
sie können eine nachfrage stellen ich
bedanke mich für die worte und hat sich
da auf die nachfrage
danke damit geht das rederecht an die
kollegin susanne ferschl von der
fraktion die linke
vielen dank frau präsidentin herr
bundeskanzler
ich hoffe sie haben sich mittlerweile zu
den fakten kundig gemacht mini jobs
verdrängen reguläre beschäftigung das
ist nicht bestandteil linker flugblätter
sondern es belegen wissenschaftliche
studien allen voran die des erb- und sie
führt insbesondere bei frauen dazu dass
dienen darf teilzeit falle feststecken
beides schließen sie jetzt letztendlich
in dem koalitionsvertrag aus versprechen
also da dass es nicht zu einer
verdrängung kommt das ist nicht zu einer
teilzeit falle kommt und die frage wie
wollen sie dieses versprechen
realisieren wenn sie die mini jobs aber
gleichzeitig ausweiten
das was in deutschland stattfindet ist
etwas über das ich sehr froh bin wir
haben endlich in aussicht eine
gesetzgebung über einen höheren
mindestlohn von 12 euro der in diesem
jahr noch kommen wird der wird dazu
führen dass viele viele millionen
arbeitnehmern und arbeitnehmer mehr geld
verdienen als sie gegenwärtig verdienen
in diesem zusammenhang haben wir ein
festes verhältnis für die höhe des der
minijobs im verhältnis zu dem
entwicklung des mindestlohns beschrieben
das ist ein stück rationalität für die
zukunft aber wir haben genau wegen der
von ihnen gestellten frage uns auch
gedanken gemacht wie kann man den
übergang möglichst gut organisieren
damit niemand der jetzt wegen des
höheren mindestlohns mehr geld verdient
gewissermaßen sich irgendwie bewegt
fühlt darauf zu verzichten jetzt
sozialversichert beschäftigt zu sein und
deshalb ist das ein teil des
gesetzgebungsvorhabens dass wir auf den
weg gebracht haben hier die kleine zone
noch freundlicher auszugestalten mit der
klaren perspektive jeder höhere lohn
soll auch zu einem höheren
nettoeinkommen führen das ist die
zielsetzung
sie können nachrichten danke frau
präsidentin der bundeskanzler
mindestlohn ist das entsprechende
stichwort die mini jobs bei einer
gleichzeitig fehlenden
arbeitszeiterfassung sind das
haupteinfallstor beim mindestlohn betrug
und sie warten jetzt auf der einen seite
die minijob regelung ausführen aber
nicht die manipulationssichere
arbeitszeiterfassung 1 das heißt wir
wollen sie sicherstellen dass nicht
weiterhin millionen beschäftigte um
ihren ihnen zustehenden mindestlohn
betrogen werden und wie wollen sie dafür
sorgen dass die erhöhung auch
entsprechend beiden kolleginnen und
kollegen ankommt auch die arbeitszeit
von minijobbern muss dokumentiert werden
da gibt es keinen unterschied zu
denjenigen die normale
arbeitsverhältnisse haben das soll man
teile ich ihre prämisse nicht und
selbstverständlich gehört auch zum
arbeitsleben wie im öffentlichen leben
ansonsten auch dass es notwendig ist
dass recht und ordnung auch durchgesetzt
werden in diesem fall recht und ordnung
auf dem arbeitsmarkt und die dazu
notwendige behörde es den letzten jahren
beständig ausgebaut worden und wird auch
weiter ausgebaut werden sage ich im
hinblick auf dem das vorantreibenden
hinter mir sitzen den bundesminister der
finanzen wir werden den zoll und die
finanzkontrolle schwarzarbeit so
ausbauen dass sie sich darauf verlassen
können wir gegen alten betrugsversuchen
hinterher
nächste fragestellerin ist die kollegin
dagmar andres von der spd fraktion
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr bundeskanzler unbestritten
ist der krieg in der ukraine eine
ungeahnte herausforderungen
beispielslose art und damit auch eine
bewährungsprobe für den zusammenhalt
innerhalb europas egal ob jetzt aufgrund
der wirtschaftlichen und sozialen folgen
auf grund der flucht bewegungen oder
auch aufgrund der akuten militärischen
bedrohung durch russland vor diesem
hintergrund möchte ich sie fragen in
welchen bereichen ist europa jetzt
besonders gefordert und in welchen
bereichen eröffnen sich durch diese
krise womöglich auch neue spielräume
neue chancen um den europäischen
zusammenhalt weiter voranzubringen und
können sie bitte konkretisieren welche
impulse die bundesregierung hier in den
nächsten wochen und monaten setzen wird
schönen dank
angesichts der ukraine krise kann man
sagen hat sich der russische präsident
ja mehrfach verrechnet er hat sich
verrechnet in den blick auf den
widerstand der ukraine ukraine dieses
die russische invasion ja
zurückgeschlagen haben im verhältnis zu
dem was da ursprünglich intendiert war
wie das weitergeht das können wir alle
hier nicht vorhersagen aber das was dort
an widerstand geleistet worden es war
sehr groß aber hat sich auch verrechnet
in hinblick auf die einigkeit von uns
allen auch die einigkeit der
europäischen union die sich an den
global vereinbarten sanktions paketen
mit großer wärme beteiligt hat sie mit
vorangetrieben hat und diese einigkeit
müssen wir jetzt nutzen für große
fortschritte in europa damit dass ein
momentum ergibt es weit darüber hinaus
geht aus meiner sicht ist es wichtig
dass wir jetzt solidarisch mit den
herausforderungen umgehen die sich auch
durch die russische aggression
und die wirtschaftlichen folgen auch der
sanktions entscheidungen ergeben und das
bedeutet wir müssen zuallererst dafür
sorgen dass europa was die
energieversorgung betrifft auf eigenen
füßen steht und sich unabhängig macht
von fossilen ressourcen insbesondere den
notwendigkeit kohle öl und gas zu
importieren genau das tun wir mit den
paketen in europa besprochen werden und
das ist der eine große notwendige
bausteine für fortschritt und einigkeit
in europa
sie können an den nachfragen stehen sie
verzichten dann
geht das fragerecht über an den nächsten
kollegen das ist florian hahn von der
cdu csu fraktion
sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler
sie haben vorhin ausgeführt dass
vorgängerregierungen noch nie waffen in
krisengebiete
geliefert hätten möchte an der stelle
daran erinnern dass die schwarz rote
bundesregierung
2014 waffen in das krisengebiet irak
konkret an die per schmerker kurden
geliefert hat zum übrigen gottseidank
und mit großem erfolg die frage ist also
was es mit ihrer aussage von freund zu
halten richtig ist auch dass die ukraine
schon länger
waffenlieferungen gerne hätte aus
deutschland und auch ihre regierung erst
sozusagen mit dem eintritt des krieges
sich um entschieden hat und diesen
waffenlieferungen diese
waffenlieferungen genehmigt hat ist das
richtige wir sind die regierung die
diese entscheidung getroffen haben und
die reden entscheidung ist richtig
also die vorgängerregierung hat das auch
entwickeln nach plan herr bundeskanzler
ich möchte sie außerdem fragen es gibt
eine große diskrepanz zwischen dem was
wir
öffentlich wahrnehmen was die
bundesregierung auf der einen seite
selber postuliert im sinne von wir
liefern so viel wie geht und dem was auf
der anderen seite auf der liste in der
geheimschutzstelle zu sehen ist oder was
auch tatsächlich in der öffentlichkeit
zu lesen ist oder auch was die ukraine
tatsächlich sozusagen als feedback auf
diese lieferungen gibt meine frage ist
wie kann es sein dass wir über so viel
wochen praktisch keine veränderungen
haben bei der ausfuhr
waffen mit blick auf die entsprechende
liste in der geheimschutzstelle und wie
passt das zusammen mit den äußerungen
der bundesregierung und wie passt es
damit zusammen dass sich die
bundesverteidigungsministerium damit
rühmt das deutschland der zweitgrößte
unterstützer beim thema
waffenlieferungen ist nach den usa
obwohl bekanntermaßen andere länder
deutlich mehr geliefert haben
schönen dank für ihre frage erst mal ist
es so dass wir in der tat durch liefern
wir haben am anfang das gemacht aus den
beständen die wir von in der bundeswehr
haben und die verfügbar sind und die
sich um waffen drehen die auch sinnvoll
sind und die auch einen ganz erheblichen
beitrag geleistet haben zu dem
militärischen aktivitäten der
ukrainischen armee spreche hier von den
panzerabwehrwaffen zum beispiel den
flugabwehrwaffen viel munition und
vielen was dazu gehört und wir sind
dabei jetzt gewissermaßen die bundeswehr
um deren stärkung wir uns ansonsten ja
auch noch gedanken machen damit sie ihm
viele bestände hat die viel größer sind
als heute dass nebenbei welche
möglichkeiten existieren für
industrielle lieferung darüber haben wir
sehr sorgfältig all die verschiedenen
angebote der industrie betrachtet und
bewertet und unsere vorstellungen dazu
entwickelt und sind jetzt im engen
austausch mit der ukraine was dort
möglich ist sie wissen dass wir im
übrigen alles dafür getan haben dass
auch die finanziellen
handlungsmöglichkeiten der ukraine dazu
groß sind die eu hat mittlerweile eine
milliarde euro bereitgestellt für die
beschaffung von waffen und das ist auch
richtig
nächste fragestellerin ist die kollegin
lisa bader aus fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen
sehr gute frau präsidentin sehr geehrter
herr bundeskanzler
dieser krieg in europa hat uns ja auch
vor augen geführt wie eng energiepolitik
und sicherheitspolitik verzahnt sind sie
hatten darauf hingewiesen und das uns
unsere fossile abhängigkeit natürlich
auch verwundbar macht und ich sag mal
die co2 emissionen die sind das
spiegelbild dieser abhängigkeit der
weltklimarat hat diese woche noch mal
gesagt dass die unvermindert steigen
weltweit von daher wie ich es sehr
begrüßenswert dass sie heute sagen jetzt
erst recht wir müssen mehr tun im kampf
gegen den menschengemachten klimawandel
und von daher wäre meine frage
vielleicht können sie noch einmal
konkret sagen in welchen bereichen in
der energiepolitik sowohl national als
auch auf eu ebene müssen aus ihrer sicht
die ambition nochmal angeschärft werden
damit wir letztendlich unabhängiger und
damit auch um verwundbarer werden
es gibt wirklich eingangs gesagt habe
zwei
unterschiedliche fragestellungen zu
beantworten was machen wir schnell und
unmittelbar um die abhängigkeit von den
russischen importen zu reduzieren da
geht es auch um investitionen für zb
flüssiggas terminals an den
norddeutschen küsten und ähnliche
entscheidungen die etwas mit dem import
fossiler ressourcen zu tun haben bei dem
flüssiggas terminals ist das gute das
wir sie sowieso brauchen nämlich für den
später geplanten import auch von
wasserstoff der zu einer klimaneutralen
industriellen zukunft um die mitte des
jahrhunderts für europa spätestens 2 45
in deutschland dazu gehört und deshalb
ist es für uns ganz ganz wichtig dass
wir genau in diesem bereich die
notwendigen fortschritte jetzt zustande
bringt unser stromnetz ausbauen dafür zu
sorgen dass wir ein ordentliches
wasserstoff netz bekommen dafür sorge zu
tragen dass wir produktionskapazitäten
bekommen für windkraft auf hoher see
land für solarenergie für die
möglichkeiten die damit verbunden sind
das machen wir auch in dem wir die
möglichkeit mehr auf strom zu setzen
verbessern indem die kostenbelastung die
mit der eeg umlage für die stromnetze
rinnen und nutzer heute verbunden sind
abgeschafft wird aber das machen wir
eben auch mit einem massiven boom bei
den investitionen das ist der weg den
deutschland geht wo wir heute einen
wichtigen schritt für gegangen sind aber
es ist der weg der für ganz europa
richtig ist
sie können eine nachfrage stimmt ja
vielen dank herr bundeskanzler
insbesondere auch für die aussicht dass
wir unsere gas partnerschaft natürlich
auch in grüne erneuerbare und
wasserstoff partnerschaften umwandeln
wollen in der zukunft jenseits dessen
was der bund tun muss ist natürlich eine
riesige herausforderung und ich denke
sie sehen es auch so dass wir die länder
in unserer seite brauchen haben sie den
eindruck dass manche bundesländer
vielleicht auch mit wenigen maßnahmen
noch mehr tun können um diese ambitionen
zu erhöhen zb beim windkraft ausbauen
und uns darauf zu unterstützen na wenn
der windkraftausbau überall in
deutschland voran gehen muss muss ja
überall in deutschland vorangehen und
das ist also in allen 16 ländern davon
das fragerecht geht jetzt an den
kollegen marc bernhard aus der fdp
fraktion
danke frau präsidentin
bundeskanzler deutschland importiert
derzeit rund 55 prozent seines erdgases
und die hälfte der steinkohle aus
russland und es hat gestern die
eu-kommission ja den importverbot für
russische kohle vorgeschlagen und dessen
es auch möglich und sie haben ja selber
auch gesagt dass wir da dringend
wegkommen muss müssen aber wir können
sofort machen denn ein einziges
kernkraftwerk liefert so viel energie
wie beispielsweise fünf prozent des
russischen gases oder 16 prozent der
russischen kohle wenn wir also die drei
im dezember abgeschalteten
kernkraftwerke reaktivieren würden
können sie zusammen mit den drei noch
aktiven fast den gesamten russischen
kohle importieren oder eben 30 prozent
des russischen gases und jetzt meine
frage jetzt haben sie eine zeitenwende
einer angekündigt herr bundeskanzler
wasser die regierung unternommen um die
laufzeitverlängerung und wieder
inbetriebnahme der kernkraftwerke in
deutschland zeitnah zu erreichen um eben
für bezahlbare energie und für
unabhängigkeit von russischen
energielieferungen zu sorgen also
zunächst mal wenn die welt so einfach
wäre
wie sie sich in ihrer frage malen dann
hätten wir dann hätten wir ein sehr
gutes leben aber tatsächlich ist es so
dass zum beispiel ein großer teil der
fossilen importe die wir haben für
industrielle prozesse benötigt wird 80
prozent der energie in deutschland
verbraucht wird wird im wesentlichen im
bereich der industrie verbraucht und
deshalb dürfen wir uns nicht ein
falsches bild machen das gilt übrigens
auch für die regionale verteilung und
für die frage wo es um stromproduktion
geht muss um wärmeproduktion geht wo es
um die um rohstoffe geht die für die
industrie notwendig sind ein teil der
ölimporte wird gar nicht fürs fahren
oder heizen benutzt sondern tatsächlich
um chemische produkte herzustellen
und deshalb kann man das nicht mit
dieser einen einfachen antwort überhaupt
lösen und die zweite antwort auf ihre
frage ist es die technische wir haben
unsere atomkraftwerke darüber haben wir
aus gründen die ich sehr gut fand
richtig finde und verändert entschieden
dass wir die auslaufen lassen wollen
deswegen aber auch ist auch nicht alles
vorbereitet für einen weiterbetrieb denn
das was wir gegenwärtig alle feststellen
es gibt ja nicht nur importe von kohle
gas und öl aus russland und einigen
anderen ländern das gilt ja auch für
kernbrennstäbe und für die physik und
die ddr klaren ressourcen die notwendig
sind das sind dinge die vorbereitet und
entschieden werden müssen wo man nicht
sagen kann ich tanke mal neu das ist
glaube ich an technisches
missverständnisses eines atomkraftwerks
und deshalb ist das kein guter plan den
sie da in simulieren
sie können eine nachfrage stehen das
kannst du jetzt ist natürlich schon so
dass wir ein großteil der kohle die
momentan eben zur verstromung eingesetzt
wird der steinkohle natürlich dadurch
dann ersetzen könnten dann müssten wir
weniger aus russland importieren also
von daher wäre es schon eine schnelle
lösung auf der anderen seite muss man ja
nur mal nachprüfen man kann nämlich eben
schon brennstoffe stärkt wenn stäbe
bestellen wir uns halten preisaufschlag
dafür bezahlen aber die unabhängigkeit
sollte es uns doch wert sein man kann
auch dafür sorgen dass zunächst einmal
kernkraftwerk im teillastbetrieb weiter
laufen damit sie eine gewisse
stromerzeugung eben machen man kann die
sicherheitsbedenken aus dem weg räumen
in dem das man im sommer eben runter
fährt die sicherheitsüberprüfung machte
dass sie im winter zur verfügung stehen
und deswegen meine frage wie viele
lieferanten von brennstäben haben sie
denn angefragt und wie haben sie den und
warum wurde die mögliche
sicherheitsüberprüfung der
kernkraftwerke im sommer bisher nicht
eingeplant also ist eine zeitenwende um
die um die frage noch einmal zu
beantworten die sie gestellt haben wenn
man neue wenn man die kernkraftwerke
dauerhaft oder eine längere zeit jetzt
länger laufen lassen will braucht man
neuen kernbrennstoff der nicht einfach
verfügbar ist er auch an technische
voraussetzungen gebundenes die nicht
über nacht hergestellt werden können und
deshalb haben sie ja selber das schon
ein bisschen berücksichtigt indem sie
vorschlagen man solle die atomkraftwerke
dieses jahr weniger laufen lassen damit
sie später mehr laufen können das ist
aber die antwort auf die frage gibt es
überhaupt genug auch sie gehen davon aus
offenbar nicht und deshalb ist es so
dass wir davon aber auch nichts hätten
denn wenn wir in diesem jahr ein mangel
haben an kohle gas oder
öl falls uns das passieren würde und wir
würden dann um das auszugleichen die
kernbrennstäbe die die atomkraftwerke
weniger laufen lassen müssten wir mehr
kohle gas und öl verbrauchen das ist
also die milchmädchenrechnung von der
ich am anfang schon gesprochen habe es
geht einfach nicht aus was sie sich
ausmachen
der nächste fragesteller ist stephan
thome von der fdp-fraktion
viel lang frau präsidentin herr
bundeskanzler die beratungen auf
europäischer ebene über eine verteilung
der schutzsuchenden aus ukraine haben
leider keinen konsens über einen
verbindlichen verteilen mechanismus
geführt stattdessen ist ein freiwilliger
verteil index gefunden worden mit
freiwilligkeit etwas gutes aber eben
auch weniger verlässlich als
rechtsverbindliche verteil regeln und
niemand weiß oder hilfsbereitschaft
lange anhält oder ob sie ihren künftigen
fällen auch wieder so groß ist wie in
diesem fall deswegen ist meine frage an
sie ob sich ihre bundesregierung mit dem
jetzigen freiwilligen verteilt
mechanismus zufrieden gibt oder ob sie
gleichwohl versuchen weiterhin einen
rechtsverbindlichen tourismus für diese
künftige fälle zu vereinbaren
zunächst mal ist es gut dass ganz europa
sich verantwortlich fühlt für die
aufnahme von flüchtlingen dass es mit
den entscheidungen die die europäische
union getroffen hat verbunden dass das
keine sache 1 länder ist dass alle
bereit sind ukrainische flüchtlinge
aufzunehmen
eine entscheidung die wir in früheren
migrationsbewegung von flüchtlingen
nicht hatten und deshalb auch
wahrscheinlich einen
politikwechsel eine politische
veränderung die weit über die
gegenwärtige herausforderung
hinausreicht trotzdem sind damit nicht
alle fragen gelöst die viren untermarke
hatten und für einen festen gesetzlichen
gilt geltenden verteil mechanismus hat
sich eben wie auch in der vergangenheit
keine mehrheit gefunden deshalb ist die
regelung die wir jetzt haben ein großer
fortschritt zu dem was wir in der
vergangenheit hatten und was ich ihnen
versichern kann ist dass wir alles dafür
tun diese erklärte solidarität und
diesen mechanismus auch mit leben zu
erfüllen und in enger kooperation mit
den anderen europäischen ländern sie zu
bitten sich an der aufnahme auf
verantwortung zu
sie können einen anfang stehen wenn sie
erlauben eine nachfrage ich finde sie
sagen zu recht dass die qualität mit
flüchtlingen keine sache einzelner
länder ist sondern gemeinschaftsaufgabe
ganz europas oder vielleicht auch nicht
nur europas deswegen ist meine frage ob
sie auch in verbindung mit anderen
regierungen steht etwa nordamerikas usa
und kanadas ob auch diese länder falls
der zustrom lange anhalten sollte eine
große zahl von menschen weiterkommen
sollte auch diese länder bereit sind
flüchtende aufzunehmen die bereitschaft
ist von vielen erklärt worden die zahlen
sind natürlich
bisher nicht sehr groß die da real die
bewegung hin gefunden haben also das
fängt schon an mit unserem unmittelbaren
befreundeten nachbarn großbritannien
geht weiter bekannter da und die usa was
aber nicht nur an diesen ländern nicht
sondern auch an den ukrainischen
flüchtlingen selber die alle für sich
entschieden haben dass sie möglichst
dicht dran bleiben wollen an dem land
aus dem sie kommen weil ja viele noch
die perspektive verfolgen dass sie auch
schnell wieder zurückkommen wollen
insofern wird sich das über die zeit
sicher ändern aber ich habe die
zusicherung von den regierungschefs
aller dieser drei länder die ich genannt
habe und noch manch anderer dass sie
sich darum bemühen werden und dass sie
aktiv an beitrag zur aufnahme leisten
wollen der kanadische premierminister
hat mir zum beispiel auch gesagt das
haben wir vor knapp 100 jahren nach
kanada eine massive ukrainische
migration gegeben die sehr dazu
beigetragen habe dass heutige kanada
aufzubauen
deshalb geht er von einer großen
bereitschaft vieler bürger bürger mit
verwandtschaftsverhältnissen in die
ukraine hinaus auch hier einen beitrag
zu leisten
so wir blenden uns an dieser stelle aus
und schalten noch einmal ganz kurz zu
meiner kollegin ines trams ines haben
wir da gerade einen typischen olaf
scholz erlebt kurze knappe antworten
aber wenig neues wenig konkretes zum
beispiel zu weiteren sanktionen der eu
ganz genau er wurde wenig konkret beim
thema waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
bzw einem energie embargo gegen russland
da stand er in dieser fragerunde ganz
klar unter druck aber auch die
schrecklichen bilder des massakers von
butscher so scheint es heute ändern die
haltung von kanzler scholz nicht er
sprach zwar von einem kriegsverbrechen
er sprach nicht mehr von einem
mutmaßlichen kriegsverbrechen aber
weitergehende maßnahmen konkrete
maßnahmen mit blick auf ein mögliches
gas embargo oder waffenlieferungen
erwähnte er nicht
ja soweit vielen dank ihnen ist und auch
bei ihnen bedanke ich mich für ihr
interesse hier geht es jetzt weiter mit
heute in deutschland ich wünsche ihnen
noch einen schönen tag und sage tschüss
bis zum nächsten mal